hello everyone it's seven o'clock
another unwanted milestone in the worst
cost of living crisis in a generation
could be hit this morning the cost of
filling an average family car is
forecast to take over 100 pounds for the
first time a day after the biggest daily
fuel price jump in 17 years it's a blow
to the prime minister's attempt to make
a fresh start as he prepares to
potentially extend the right to buy
scheme to help people get on the
property ladder we'll ask the levelling
up secretary michael gove if it's really
going to work the shadow leveling up
secretary lisa nandi's also on the
programme plus we'll talk to the former
nato secretary general anderso rasmussen
to get his take on what the future holds
for ukraine and president putin
it's thursday the 9th of june
pumping us for more money the price of
petals set to hit a painful new high
costing us 100 pounds to fill up a
family car
from revolt to reforms reports the prime
minister may extend the right to buy
schemes so lower paid workers can use
housing benefits to buy homes
a legal challenge to the plan to send
asylum seekers to rwanda the sky news
speaks to someone facing that fate
through a translator
i will face certain that i will be
executed but i prefer to be executed in
iran rather than being
centered wonder
[Music]
stubbing out a bad habit the move that
could raise the legal smoking age every
year to stop youngsters doing it we'll
bring you this breaking story on this
morning's show
we'll reveal new details about the
driver of a car that hit a crowd killing
a teacher and injuring 14 students
pulled after protests cinemas dropped
the film about the prophet muhammad's
daughter after it sparked outrage we'll
talk to the producer and the protest
organizer at half past eight
also this morning
for our dear friend the foo fighters
announced two all-star tribute gigs in
london and
la in memory of the drummer taylor
hawkins
[Music]
and i'll be joined by the actor max
beasley who's starring in a new sky max
drama reimagining the classic science
fiction novel the midwitch cuckoos
[Music]
hello good morning the prime minister
this morning is setting his sides firmly
on pressing the reset button with a
major speech on housing it's been
reported that he may extend the right to
buy scheme to lower paid workers
allowing them to use their housing
benefits to buy homes well we'll ask the
leveling up secretary michael go shortly
how it'll work
plus the cost of living crisis is set to
squeeze us all more from today with the
price of filling up an average family
car with petrol expected to top 100
pounds for the first time we'll bring
you those figures
live at half past nine
so what is the state of play on the four
courts well the average price of
unleaded petrol
is now 180.73
pence per liter that is up more than 2
pence in the last 24 hours the largest
daily increase in 17 years
diesel is also up and now averages
186.57
pence a liter that's up more than one
pence since the day before
well petrol prices have risen by 36.4
percent over the last year it means the
average family car with a 55-litre tank
now costs 99 pounds 40 pence to fill
with unleaded and all eyes are on the
rac's latest data dropping around half
past nine this morning which could see
this figure tick over the 100 pound mark
for the first time ever
well skies ashna hurunag is at a petrol
station for us this morning uh
what are the figures looking like there
well at the moment jane you're looking
at sort of 197 here and that's just
petrol but as you say it's never been so
expensive to fill up your car on monday
we're talking about 178 at pence per
litre on tuesday at roseboro another 2p
the highest that figure has jumped in a
day in 17 years a trajectory that's
simply not sustainable the government in
march introduced a cut to fuel duty by
five pence but there are some concerns
that fuel duality is not being reflected
on some poor ports there are now
suggestions that retailers should be
named and shamed if they don't give that
discount to consumers look on some
places though it is much higher on the
motorway down this morning in some
service stations you're looking at more
than two pounds per liter already and
diesel is already at a record high the
ric says though the peak is yet to come
thanks very much well i'm joined now by
the leveling up secretary michael gove
here in the studio i mean it's
astonishing isn't think it's going to
cost over 100 pounds for most people to
fill up their car how high does the
government expect fuel prices to go well
the situation is difficult for many
people um and of course it's all
consequence of uh the war in ukraine and
again we don't know uh uh how the
the shock waves of that wall will
continue to affect the energy market and
the price of petrol for people who are
hard-pressed and filling up their cars
but we have taken action to try to deal
with this situation and the chance does
reduce fuel duty um and of course we
keep under review all the measures
necessary in order to help people with
the cost of living but that five pence
fueled duty and as much as has been
wiped out it was wiped out almost within
the week actually by by the increasing
prices
could the chancellor cut it further well
we always keep things under review but
one of the things we do want to make
sure is that that cut and fuel duty is
being passed on to the consumer so one
of the things that we do need to do is
to make sure that um on every four court
that uh every uh
outlet is making sure that it doesn't uh
take advantage of this situation to
build up excess profit advantage well i
think we do need to keep a a watch on
this and i know that the competition and
markets authority
and others will always keep an eagle eye
in order to ensure that we don't have a
situation where companies are taking
unfair advantage of consumers
supermarkets some some putting up prices
by as much as five pence a day is there
nothing the government can do to stop
that well uh as i say it is important
that we look at the uh the behavior of
individual retailers supermarkets and
others and see what the pattern of
evidence leads us uh to conclude um but
i think it's also important that we do
all recognize that the ultimate cause of
the increase in uh oil prices the
increase in energy costs overall is war
in ukraine um it's a it's a devastating
conflict but we do need to make sure
that russia does not um profit from its
aggression but what about the fuel
companies themselves that should they be
taking lower profits do you think are
there any in particular that you've got
your eye on well uh again you know the
the uh the chancellor has been clear um
with uh the uh
energy level that he's introduced but
those companies that are making huge
windfall profits will pay their way into
helping people um with the cost of
living challenges that we all face at
the moment um nobody likes increasing
taxes but the chancellor is vigilant and
on the side of those people who are
struggling most at this time
but but what about the supermarkets what
about the the people delivering the fuel
could they not
should the profits that they are making
not be targeted as well well uh
as i mentioned earlier there are uh
government agencies that are in a
position to monitor what's happening um
again i don't want to single anyone out
because these are tough times for
companies as well as individuals but if
it is the case that we do have companies
that are behaving in a way which is
anti-competitive uh if we have companies
that are taking advantage of this crisis
in order to generate profits that are uh
uh excessive and unwarranted because
they're behaving in an anti-competitive
fashion then we can take action okay
let's move on to the uh plans that are
we're expecting the prime minister
announced today uh it's about right to
buy isn't it it's about helping people
who are on housing benefit buy their
homes this was an idea of course that
was pioneered by margaret thatcher that
she later said she regretted
and has been derided by a lot of people
why is the prime minister announcing it
and why now i think the only people who
are deriding it are people who um in
many cases themselves own their own
homes um and don't want to see the the
prize of homeownership extended i think
the the criticism of it was that when
these social housing houses were passed
over into more people's ownership they
weren't replaced and so therefore there
wasn't the social housing to to help
those coming up behind who needed it
that is a fair point and one of the
things that we will be doing is making
sure that there is a replacement i will
like for like one for one replacement
how long would that take though because
of course we all know that developers
are sitting on loads of land oh yeah
it's hard to get social housing built
and a lot of social housing is built as
a one or two flats and a big private
development well we're taking steps
yesterday um i introduced legislation to
the house of commons that means that
there will be a new levy on developers
that means that when new developments
occur um when new homes are built for
sale by the big housing companies we
will extract some of the money that they
make because when planning permission is
granted the value of land increases will
take that money out and some of that
money will be set aside explicitly to
make sure that there is more affordable
housing more council housing for people
who need it but how how can you say this
is going to happen within a set time
frame i mean you know if if a council
sells 20 houses today to tenants
it's not going to they're not going to
have 20 new houses tomorrow for the next
lot of tenants it's going to take years
well the the way in which the levy works
means that people can be assured that
when planning permission is granted for
new development that there will be money
uh in due course but it's a long term
council's councils can
borrow against that in order to invest
the truth with uh housing is that we
need more homes of all kinds we need
them in the right places we need them to
be high quality we need them to be
beautiful we need to be appropriate
infrastructure alongside that but one of
the ways in which we can do that um as
on legislation that we introduced
yesterday uh uh demonstrates is by
having a a planning system that is
sensitive but also welcomes the right
development
in terms of the money though my
understanding and correct me if i'm
wrong is that you can't get means tested
benefits if you have savings of 16 000
pounds anybody who wants to buy a home
and unless they're getting 100 more
which needs some kind of deposit if you
if you've got 15 000 pounds say 14 999
so you don't you don't go over that cap
that that's a tiny deposit for any house
there are no homes in the uk that you
can get for a hundred thousand
especially in london of course how how
on earth is the government going to
square this financial circle there are
properties outside london than you can
but you are quite right um but one of
the challenges and there are two one is
um making sure that we have more new
homes the other one is making sure that
people have access to mortgage finance
and one of the things that we're looking
at is a way in which uh people can save
explicitly for home ownership and that
those savings can be disregarded or set
aside for the purposes of people
receiving the benefits to which they are
entitled so we're looking specifically
at a savings vehicle that people can use
in order to make sure that they can save
for that deposit because homeownership
is not just good for individuals it's
good for society overall we want people
to have a stake in the future we want
people to be able to invest in their own
home we want people to have somewhere
safe and secure warm and decent in which
they can raise their children but if
people are on means tested benefit and
just look at the fuel prices today the
cost of food as a result of the ukraine
crisis most people are on means tested
benefits are worried about getting
through to the end of the week or to the
end of the month they're not going to be
able to put aside money it's it's it's a
pipe dream for most people that they can
possibly save as much as ten thousand
pounds well well you are right that
times are tough at the moment and you're
also right that the number of people who
uh can aspire to homeownership has been
reducing over time that's why we're
taking action um and this action is
intended to ensure that once we we
weather the particular economic
difficulties that we face at the moment
uh that we can ensure that people are
back on the path to home ownership uh
it's absolutely vital that we uh reverse
the decline in homeownership that we've
seen over recent years isn't there also
the issue though that if you do sell
homes to people at a reduced price
because that is that is also part of it
that would make it easier for people on
low incomes to buy them
the cost of replacing that that property
is more than the cost of selling it
there was a um a pilot scheme in the
midlands back in 2018.
authorities there said they'd replace
one form the average sale price was 137
000 um but to build a new house to
replace that was 280 000. so
this costs an absolute fortune for the
government if you're going to be you
know spending a hundred thousand pounds
to replace each house that's a huge
amount of money where will that come
from is this new money uh it is it will
come from the overall parcel the overall
envelope of government spending at the
moment um we expect that we will cap the
number of people who will be able to
benefit from this initially and then it
will grow over time but it's important
that government does invest in bricks
and mortar and one of the things one of
the things that my department does
already is to spend hundreds of millions
of pounds
in making sure that we can assemble the
land necessary to build more homes
particularly in urban areas because
there is a pressing need when we have so
many people on waiting lists so many
people in temporary accommodation to see
more homes built and that means more
social homes as well as more homes to
earn what what will the cap be of people
who can do it uh well we're thinking um
at the moment about exactly how many can
benefit each year and that's something
i'll be discussing with housing
associations because again of course we
have the resources to be able to to fund
um a program of this kind but we want to
make sure that housing associations come
with us and they recognize that their
balance sheets are going to be robust in
the event of you must have offerings if
you're costing it uh we have costed it
but but again i don't want to get into
speculation about it
you know 100 people a thousand people uh
uh more than that but but but again one
of the things one of the things that i
know is that once you get involved in a
property auction uh like this you never
know where the numbers are going to be
so i won't get involved in speculating
at this stage
about the exact numbers because the
problem is when you don't talk about the
exact numbers it leads people to say
well hang on if we don't know exactly
how many people is this could be you
know half a dozen people
it's a very catchy policy which the
government is rolling out in a week
which has been a really tough week for
the government and and you know some
would say oh interesting timing that
this has been popped out this week uh
well it's part of a package of uh
housing policy on which we've been uh
working four months now and as well as
the uh extending the right to housing
association tenants it's also the case
that we're overhauling the planning
system it's also the case uh as i say
that we have a new infrastructure levy
that ensures that we can get more money
from developers it's also the case that
yesterday um we announced new powers for
uh the social housing regulator to make
sure that social homes are decent there
is a big range of policies uh that the
government is bringing forward in order
to make sure that people can own their
own home and that for those who are
renting that there is appropriate
protection as well so this has been in
the pipeline for some time and it is
part of the the suite of policies that
the government is bringing forward to
show that we're um are on your side at a
time of economic difficulty
let's move away from housing to the
situation uh with asylum seekers in
rwanda uh there was a plane due to take
a number of people out next week and
there have been a number of protests
about it it looks like the home
secretary's plan is going to face a
legal challenge
do you think this is a realistic
way of stopping this do you think that
this play next week will actually go
yes i do um and the home secretary was
clear uh she always anticipated we
always anticipated that there would be
legal challenges uh there are some uh uh
well-funded law firms uh that uh
understandably uh from their point of
view uh want to uh test this policy but
we believe that it is the right policy
we've secured
a cooperation agreement with rwanda um
which means that uh
we will be in a position to
support that country and also support
them as they accept asylum seekers who
come here it's absolutely vital that we
take steps to break the business model
of people smugglers who are trading in
human misery what we want is a robust
but also fair policy on immigration so
you're not worried
uh no and i think it's also fair to say
that uh at the same time as we're
dealing with the uh the problem of uh
people smuggling um and illegality in
our migration system we're also showing
generosity the british people are
showing generosity uh towards people
from ukraine uh my department has been
responsible for working with the home
office and as a result we have more than
60 000 people who've come from ukraine
uh in the last few weeks and months to
the uk and i think that the british
people want to see
our borders protected
tough and robust laws enforced but at
the same time generosity extended to
those people who are in genuine
suffering generosity compassion open
mindedness things all things that we
would like to be known for in the uk and
we've got a film about the daughter of
the prophet muhammad which has been
pulled from a number of uk cinemas uh we
spoke to sergey javid yesterday he said
he was very concerned about growing
cancer culture
do you agree with him over this i always
agree with the health secretary
on everything uh i can't think of
anything in which i disagree with
saturday but possibly sports a different
football team to me but apart from that
i don't know
so you get on well with him um
what about the leader how did you vote
for him this week did you did you give
him your your support on monday
enthusiastically yes uh i think that
it's because you've not always been an
enthusiastic friend or supporter have
you no i i made a mistake in 2016. um uh
uh a misjudgment um if you've been in
politics for a little while as i have
been then um you know there are always
mistakes that you can look back on but
no i think the prime minister is doing a
good job um yeah i've been privileged to
work alongside him uh a when he made
sure that the the brexit entanglement
the imbroglio was broken um i worked
alongside him particularly during the
clover crisis uh he was
uh uh very seriously ill recovered
recovered in order to lead
the world's most successful vaccination
program and a booster program that saw
us emerge from covid ahead of other
economies and also um we've been
touching on the situation in in ukraine
um you don't need to take it from me
just uh listen to what uh velodrome
zolensky said when he heard that the
prime minister had won the uh confidence
vote on monday he um an embattled war
leader expressed his uh delight that uh
that boris uh
in his own words you know one of the
strongest allies the ukrainian people
have uh had been vindicated in that vote
so you wouldn't run against him as a
potential new leader oh god no
what would you say to the uh 148 mps who
didn't agree with you have you been out
rallying for him yes i know i can
understand why uh uh some of my
mp colleagues
have concerns um and i think it's
important that um over the course of the
the next two years that we demonstrate
that the government is focused um on
delivering for uh for everyone across
the united kingdom um so you know one of
the things i think we need to to do is
to uh move away from a concentration on
uh some of the you know the westminster
uh preoccupations towards the people's
priorities um and in that sense you know
what the prime minister was saying today
uh in blackpool about extending home
ownership um and about helping more
people onto the property letter that is
exactly i know
a concern that many of my colleagues
have um and i hope that uh however they
voted on monday when they look at what
the prime minister is saying and what
this government is doing that it will
feel reassured that we're on track to
deliver uh what we were uh elected to
deliver in 2019. michael gove thanks
very much for coming and for joining us
not at all thank you
well let's get a quick look at the
morning's papers the telegraph is
leading on fears that the price of a
tank of petrol could hit a hundred
pounds for the first time after petrol
prices jumped by two pence yesterday
100 pounds to fill your family car
that's the headline in the mirror which
calls the rise in fuel prices a petrol
crisis
the guardian also focuses on that hike
and petrol prices the biggest daily
price rise in 17 years along with the
forecast that the uk's economy is set to
slow to a standstill next year
the financial times leads on the warning
from the oecd that apart from russia the
uk is on track for the worst growth in
the g20
the times says that the prime minister
will today announce plans which would
let lower paid workers use their housing
benefits to buy a house and end rules
that prevent the use of welfare payments
to get mortgages
meanwhile the express reports boris
johnson will set out his most radical
move yet to cut household bills in the
wide-ranging speech
three days of rail strikes at the end of
june will disrupt trains for almost a
week according to the eye with just one
in five passenger services expected to
run
and the daily mail has a word that the
coalition of charities and border force
trade unions are mounting a legal
challenge to hold plans to deport
migrants to rwanda
well let's get more on that story we
were just talking about with michael
gove this legal challenge launched by
human rights groups to halt next week's
planned deportation of asylum seekers
from britain to rwanda
as we were discussing there with the
leveling up secretary he says it doesn't
worry him well british government
announced in april it had struck a deal
to send potentially tens of thousands of
asylum seekers to the east african
nation our home office workers told sky
news that they are worried that the plan
puts lives at risk they spoke out just
days before the first flight is due to
leave our communities correspondent lisa
holland reports
no more charter flights
there are just a few days now until the
first flight is due to leave and
campaigners are doing all they can to
stop it demonstrating outside the
rwandan high commission and launching
multiple legal challenges
but sky news has learned of concerns
raised inside the home office where the
strategy is being implemented
we've spoken to a home office worker
who's been in the asylum department for
a number of years their words are posed
and voiced by an actor i feel quite
ashamed to work for the home office i
think this policy is disgraceful to be
honest there's disbelief this flight
will happen
the government says it wants to end the
trade of people smugglers transporting
asylum seekers across the channel in
small boats instead it plans to send an
uncapped number of people to rwanda to
have their claims heard it feels like
we're taking part in human trafficking
transporting people against their will
and paying another country to take them
the majority of staff who work for the
home office or in it to try and make
people's lives better but we feel like
we're being forced to implement a policy
that is the opposite of that
this is an iranian man who we're calling
barham who we can reveal is one of the
first asylum seekers due to be sent to
rwanda
he's seen here giving evidence at an
international human rights tribunal last
november
he says he was a police commander in
iran but fled after refusing to fire on
anti-government demonstrators
he's now in a detention center near
gatwick airport after crossing the
channel but told of his fear what will
happen next speaking by phone through a
translator
sending me back to iran
for you i will face certain death i will
be executed but i prefer to be executed
in iran rather than being
centered wanda barham has been sent this
removal notice telling him he's on a
direct flight to kigali airport in
rwanda on june the 14th plans are so
advanced he's been told he has a luggage
allowance of 25 kilos he's refused to
sign the form
housed in accommodation like this the
home office says it will work with the
rwandan government to offer safety to
those seeking asylum and those
recognized as refugees will be given the
opportunity to rebuild their lives
critics don't believe that and say
they'll fight the policy every step of
the way lisa holland sky news
the government could be about to raise
the age at which people in england are
allowed to smoke
a report commissioned by the health
secretary is expected to suggest that
the legal age be raised every year so
the current generation of children will
never be able to buy tobacco products
a shortage of cancer doctors across the
uk could be leading to delays in
patients being diagnosed according to a
new warning from the royal college of
radiologists it's already estimated that
as many as 50 000 cancer diagnoses were
missed during the pandemic and staffing
shortages are only getting worse well
this morning the royal college of
radiologists is sounding the alarm over
these shortfalls
their report has found that 97 of
clinical directors are worried about
backlogs and delays for patients
the uk is currently
1669 radiologists short of required
standards that's a shortfall of 29
of those 200 posts have been vacant for
a year or more with west wales having
the lowest ratio of specialists
a study in the us suggests eating two
portions of fish a week could lead to an
increased risk of skin cancer
out of more than 490 000 adults surveyed
researchers from brown university found
people who consumed around 300 grams of
fish a week had a 22 percent higher risk
of malignant melanoma than those who ate
around 22 grams a week although
contributing factors that could
influence results like weight smoking
and drinking history were also taken
into account
still to come on the show i will talk to
the danish the former danish prime
minister and ex-nato secretary general
anders foe rasmussen as his foundation
hosts a democracy summit focusing on the
war in ukraine
we'll talk to the parents of a gambling
addict who took his own life as new data
reveals a higher prevalence of online
gambling in deprived areas
and just after eight i'll be joined by
the shadow leveling up housing and
communities secretary lisa nandi
[Music]
now authorities in germany say they're
keeping an open mind about possible
motives after a man drove into a crowd
in berlin a teacher was killed and 14 of
her students were injured police have
arrested the driver a 29-year-old man
with dual german armenian citizenship
well i'm joined now by siobhan robbins
who's in berlin for us and siobhan what
have we learned over over the last 12 24
hours
morning jane well we've spoken to the
police this morning who say of course
they are still investigating but at the
moment they've told us there are signs
suggesting this isn't a terror related
incident now just to remind people about
what happened yesterday it was around
half past 10 in the morning in a popular
berlin shopping street when this car
drove down a hit crowd of people
killing a teacher injuring at least 14
students and continued to then mount the
pavement a second time before crashing
into a shop now the 29 year old driver a
german armenian as you said was arrested
on the scene and is being questioned by
police but this really put fear into the
heart of berliners because it was just
moments from the site of yesterday's
crash that in 2016 there was a terror
attack where someone drove into a crowd
of people at a christmas market killing
13 people so you can imagine immediately
people were extremely
worried that this was a repeat but at
the moment interior minister here is
saying there are signs that the driver
may have been having mental health
problems and was running a mock
okay siobhan thank you
well to a developing story now and a
search is underway for two people who
are missing after a boat capsized in
devon two others were safely rescued
from roadford lake by emergency services
and are now recovering in hospital
another pair were checked over and
discharged by paramedics
twitter is reportedly planning to offer
elon musk access to its fire hose of raw
data on hundreds of millions of daily
tweets in an effort to push forward the
billionaire's acquisition of the social
media platform
musk says the deal struck in april
cannot proceed unless the company
provides more information
about the prevalence of fake accounts on
its platform
the u.s house of representatives has
voted to bring in a series of new gun
control measures including plans to
raise the minimum age for buying
semi-automatic guns from 18 to 21
but there's little hope of proposals
becoming law as the plans are expected
to be rejected at a later vote by the
senate the push comes after politicians
heard harrowing testimony about the
texas school shooting including from an
11 year old girl who survived by
covering herself in her classmate's
blood
and pretending to be
he
dead
my friend that was next to me
and i
thought he was gonna come back to the
room so i grabbed the blood
and
put it all over me
an arizona man convicted of murder in
1984
killing an eight-year-old girl has been
executed it is the state's second
execution since officials resumed
carrying out the death penalty last
month following an almost eight year
break sixty-six-year-old frank atwood
died by lethal injection for murdering
vicky lynn hoskinson whose body was
found in the desert
the few fighters have announced two
tribute concerts in order to commemorate
the life of their late drummer taylor
hawkins
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well the first gig will take place on
the 3rd of september at london's wembley
stadium with a second concert in los
angeles later that month hawkins died at
the age of 50 in march while the band
were on tour in colombia
time for the weather now
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well rain spreading in today will be
followed by unseasonably strong winds
tomorrow with gales near northwestern
coasts it's mild and fine for most but
northern britain is rather gray with fog
on the hills and near eastern coasts
island cloudy with outbreaks of rain
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now an egypt-based research team has
discovered the well-preserved remains of
a new species of dinosaur
it's been described by researchers from
mansura university as having in their
words a squashy face similar to a
bulldogs and tiny stumpy arms scientists
discovered the dinosaurs vertebrae
during an expedition uh in the desert
back in 2016 they are
obviously very pleased with their
discovery
you do wonder when you look at these
images of dinosaurs though could they
have stayed upright uh well let's return
to the 21st century uh can you imagine
what it would be like to live amongst
the dinosaurs well wonder no more
don't move
bigger why do they always have to go
bigger
the third and final installment of the
jurassic world film franchise hits uk
cinemas tomorrow
jurassic world dominion carries off
where fallen kingdom left off showcasing
humanity's attempt to co-exist with
dinosaurs
surely nothing could go wrong
and let's take a look at some of the
pictures in the papers today that have
been catching our eyes well yesterday
you may have seen a picture of a boris
johnson quassel a pastry dedicated to
the prime minister by a ukrainian cafe
well now the people of chernyhiv have
gone one step further with a museum
painting him as one of their folklore
heroes very fetching coat there they've
also named him boris caprina which
translates to
boris long
lock of hair
well to the natural world now and the
telegraph have this incredible close-up
picture of a ladybird covered in morning
dew it's absolutely stunning you get to
see it at this size you can see all the
tiny hairs coming from it they're
inactive in the winter but now that the
weather is warmer and the days are
getting longer we are going to start to
see a lot more of them
and
a perfect way to start your morning now
the express have eight new kittens
who've all become part of the royal
mail's latest stamp collection they're
all really cute these are some of the
chosen moggies who are showing us the
very best of british cats just these two
they're the best ones we've decided oh
no here we go
black one black and white one and what
about the last two
that's it only four out of eight the
other four will be furious and after the
break i'm going to talk to the former
nato secretary general and chairman of
the foundation hosting a summit focusing
on uniting democracy to push back
against author authoritarianism
[Music]
welcome back well a short while ago i
spoke to the leveling up housing and
communities secretary michael gove he
told me that the government will keep an
eagle eye on retailers taking advantage
of rising fuel prices
there are government agencies that are
in a position to monitor what's
happening um again i don't want to
single anyone out because these are
tough times for companies as well as
individuals but if it is the case that
we do have companies that are behaving
in a way which is anti-competitive uh if
we have companies that are taking
advantage of this crisis in order to
generate profits that are uh
excessive and unwarranted because
they're behaving in an anti-competitive
fashion then we can take action
well tamara is here with me now is he is
shooting a little bit of a warning
across the supermarket's bowels uh he is
but it's unclear what the government can
actually do to force supermarkets to
pass that cut on many of them say that
they are trying to do it at the moment
but whether the government can actually
force them and of course they're facing
demands um to put more government
support into helping people with petrol
prices um the average price of filling
up a family car having hit a hundred
pounds today with petrol it already
reached out with diesel a couple of
weeks ago and there's little sign that
this is going to abate so i think the
government are already facing demands
that what they have offered and the
supermarkets are not passing on is not
enough and and the right to buy scheme
that the government is re-launching
today he was very cagey about saying how
many people could benefit from it now of
course if you're only offering something
to a handful of people it doesn't cost a
great deal does that that's right boris
johnson's relaunch they say it's been in
the works for months but coincidentally
uh it is happening today he's going to
lancaster to give a big speech talking
about extending the right to buy to
tenants of housing associations i didn't
get the sense from michael gov this was
going to be a sort of big bang
transformation of the housing market
like margaret thatcher's sell-off of
council houses because when you sell off
a housing association property he said
that what they learned from doing it
last time was you have to then build a
new home that takes a couple of years
and it is more expensive because you're
building one from scratch and it is
later on in the process so the
government is going to have to he had
freely admitted there put money into it
and so the numbers will be capped
initially there have been pilot schemes
of this where housing associations did
it voluntarily um the take-up was not
huge so if the government can kind of
make this into a really big policy then
um they'll they'll need to make sure
that they've tweaked it accordingly this
is what michael gove told us about that
cap and his admission that more
borrowing would be funding it
it will come from the overall parcel the
overall envelope of government spending
at the moment um we expect that we will
cap the number of people who will be
able to benefit from this initially and
then it will grow over time but it's
important that government does invest in
bricks and mortar and one of the things
one of the things that my department
does um already is to spend hundreds of
millions of pounds in making sure that
we can assemble the land necessary to
build more homes particularly in urban
areas because there is a pressing need
when we have so many people on waiting
lists so many people in temporary
accommodation to see more homes built
and that means more social homes as well
as more homes to earn
tamara thanks very much for getting more
from you in the take just after nine
well defending ukraine will be the focus
of the copenhagen democracy summit which
begins today the event aims to unite
democratic forces to push back against
authoritarianism i'm joined now by the
former danish prime minister and former
nato secretary general anders foe
rasmussen uh good to talk to you today
sir um this year's conference of course
is set out
against the context of war in europe war
in ukraine what are you hoping will come
out of it
first of all
our purpose is to strengthen the bonds
between the world's democracies i think
we are approaching a new world order
where you have an autocratic camp led by
china and the democratic camp led by the
united states and our aim is to make
the democratic camp as strong as
possible
but how can you do that when there are
as you say enormous countries like china
like russia that aren't following
democratic principles
well um
in the run-up to this summit we have
conducted an opinion poll
which is actually the largest the
broadest opinion poll
ever done on democracy and 80 percent
of people all over the world want to
live in democracy
and
furthermore uh
the free world represents
uh around 60 percent of the global
economy so if we stand together
if we
can unite
then we represent a formidable force
that will create some respect in beijing
and moscow
even though that is the case that that
it seems that most people want to live
in a democracy every year more elections
are being dismissed aren't they
in 2022 do you think democracy is is
under threat
absolutely for the 16th consecutive year
we have seen um
a global decline in freedom and
democracy
so
i think it's time it's high time to turn
the tide
we cannot take freedom and democracy for
granted we have to fight for it and we
see that currently in ukraine the
ukrainian people is actually fighting on
behalf of all of us
and we must stop putin
otherwise he will not stop he will
continue
to uh conquer uh peaceful neighbors if
he isn't stopped in ukraine
well on the subject of ukraine and
president putin you were of course uh
secretary general of nato so you
understand it workings very well are you
comfortable with how nato has dealt with
what has happened in ukraine or do you
think they should have done more
well i think we have a duty
to help the ukrainians with everything
they need the ukrainian people has the
will to fight is our duty to provide
the means to fight
and
so far i've been
satisfied with the unprecedented unity
within the nato alliance and among
democracies
in the whole world
when it comes to delivery of weapons but
i think we can do more i think the
european union should cut off all
financing of
putin's war machine it's a good step to
introduce an embargo of oil but that
should be followed by an embargo of gas
no oil no gas purchase in russia that
would bring
putin's war machine to its knees
has nato been emboldened do you think by
what putin has done of course you've
seeing sweden and finland now talking
about membership
which they they had not done considered
for such a long time
yeah absolutely i mean
putin has achieved exactly the opposite
of what he wanted he has
against this sad backdrop of an invasion
in ukraine he has
created more unity within nato and now
he will also see nato being enlarged
with finland and sweden he gets nato
troops closer to
russian
borders so all in all
thanks to putin against this very sacked
sad backdrop
we have seen as strengthened nato
and in terms of countries doing more to
stop putin and nato doing more to stop
putin in terms of embargoes do you think
the uk is doing enough is there anything
more you would like to see us doing
i think the uk has been at the very
forefront
of helping ukraine i also appreciate
the regular
updates on intelligence provided by the
uk
so i think
ukraine can really count the uk among
its closest friends and that may also be
necessary once the war is over we have
to ensure
that it will never happen again that
ukraine will be invaded
so ukraine will need security guarantees
one way or the other and i think the uk
as well as the u.s and other big nato
allies will play a crucial role in
providing
iron-clad security guarantees
to ukraine
how do you talk about the war being over
how do you think it will play out do you
see an end game
well i think the biggest risk right now
uh is a prolonged conflict
uh because putin and russia
are experts
in
prolonged simmering frozen conflicts for
decades they have uh occupied and the
eastern part of moldova since 2008 they
have occupied upcase and south of sita
in the state of georgia since 2014 they
have been in the crimea and the eastern
part of
the runway region so i think
putin's
goal might be
to continue to destabilize and weaken
ukraine through a prolonged
conflict i think this is currently the
biggest risk and that's why we have to
deliver all the weapons that ukraine
needs
uh we we have delivered some weapons
haven't we but also although we are not
delivering fighters um officially there
are some people who've gone in there
unofficially from the uk to fight and
two of those british soldiers we know
have been captured by by the russians
possibly
now facing the death penalty is there
any hope
for them that you can offer to their
families what what do you think the
international community could do here
obviously we should do all we can to put
pressure on
russia
but i'm not in a position to
to be too optimistic in that respect we
have seen how russia
violates
all international laws and
conventions
so i think the best
tool would be to continue
a maximum pressure
on
russia the only language
that putin understands is a language of
strength
force and unity that's why we should
continue to put a maximum of pressure on
russia through delivery of all the
weapons
and cutting off all financing of
russia
but is there not also the danger that
that if you do push back too hard um
that he then escalates it further
no on the contrary i think history has
taught us
that appeasement with
dictators does not lead to peace on the
contrary it leads to
war and
conflict
and i've noted that someone
has proposed that it
would be dangerous to humiliate
putin but i mean
setting the precedent
that an aggressor
can achieve their total gains
through
a peace deal after pursuing an
unjustified
war that would only encourage other
dictators as well it would set it would
send a very dangerous
signal so i think we have only one thing
to do to continue
helping the ukrainians to win this war
okay anderson rasmussen uh former
secretary general of nato and prime
minister former of denmark as well thank
you very much for joining
us now new data reveals that twice as
many online gambling accounts are linked
to people in deprived areas compared to
the most wealthy regions the report
commissioned by the charity gamble aware
says those players are also more likely
to suffer heavy losses and found that
the online gambling industry relies on a
small percentage of customers with the
largest losses for most of its revenue
we're joining me now aliz and charles
richie whose son jack took his own life
as a result of online gambling uh really
good to talk to you both thank you very
much for joining us this morning um just
tell us a little bit about jack and how
he got into gambling and what impact it
had
well jack started gambling while he was
at school
he and a large party of his friends used
to go out and gamble in their dinner
hour and actually jack became addicted
to the
land-based equivalent of these very
uh addictive games um
it was actually the fixed stop betting
terminals but the same same things are
available online he moved online very
quickly
and he was very seriously addicted and i
and what the coroner found that his
inquest which we had last march
um was that the information available to
him and to us was absolutely woeful the
coroner used that word woeful
uh and um
to be honest i mean we're as campaigners
and we met up with other bereaved
families very quickly we formed our
charity gambling with lives and we've
been campaigning for a long time
about these uh forms of gambling that
have been found to be very very
addictive online frankly it's been known
for a long time
and
we are pleased that finally the uh
gambling industry uh partner charities
have spoken out about this with this
research
but to be honest it's taken an awful
long time and people have died along the
way
the truth is anybody addicted to these
terrible terrible forms of gambling
and and how did the addiction in
gambling contribute to his death
uh well he was very clear in his so side
note and the uh that it was because of
gambling i mean he'd been free for
months and months before he died but
he will have been induced back by some
kind of email the coroner was very clear
about it and issued three prevention of
future death notices for three different
government departments
um to say that the government has to act
to stop this
charles the the impact of this
like like drugs i suppose when a child
gets involved with that it's
far-reaching isn't it what has the
impact been on your family
well i mean it's it's obviously
transformed our lives we um as liz said
very shortly after jack's death we we
set up gambling with lives
and met with other families who'd been
similarly bereaved um and so
the charity
does obviously family support mutual and
peer support with each other and helping
families newly bereaved
but but we're campaigning you know that
that that what we what we need is to
make sure that the lessons from all the
deaths that happen every year
and public health england estimate there
are over
400 gambling related suicides every year
in england alone and the lessons need to
be learned from those deaths and so
major reforms are needed around products
and this research points to the online
casino and slot games
those games need to be made much safer
less dangerous
we also need affordability checks and i
think that this
report
really highlights that that issue about
deprivation is that the industry relies
on the majority of its profits from a
very small number of accounts
and a third of those are
families in deprived areas so we have to
have affordability checks which kick in
at a level
which are meaningful i think there's
kind of an acceptance now that there
needs to be some form of affordability
checks but but people are talking about
that well it kicks in at 500 pounds
losses a month or more that is that
these figures show that that would be a
totally inadequate response um we've got
is it three percent of accounts losing
more than two thousand pounds a year on
slots
one percent of accounts uh accounting
for 40 percent of the losses and
the
we we we have to have action on on
affordability at uh preventative
uh levels and the point is that millions
of people in the country are affected by
this
most of them are in deprived areas but
actually the minister said very recently
anybody can be addicted to these very
addictive products they have higher
addiction at risk rates than heroin it
is crazy that they are so available and
so advertised
what advice would you give liz to to
anybody who's who knows family members
who you think are heading uh in the in
the
in the direction of addiction to
gambling
it's asking what are you gambling on
because we know that some of these
products are so dangerous
what we need is proper information for
the public
but the reality is that the information
has been controlled by the industry
partner charities like gamble aware who
are subject to a voluntary
system of funding they can't afford to
be too clear with the public
about this and frankly the lack of
information has cost lives and unless
the public are properly warned like
we've been warned about smoking for
example
you know a five-year-old knows the
smoking kills who knows that gambling
kills
it's important
liz i'm so sorry we're going to have to
cut you off just because we're running
out of time in the program but
thank you both so much and thank you for
talking to us about jack
thank you thank you well if you've been
affected by anything discussed in this
interview you can always contact the
samaritans on double one six one two
three or email joe samaritans.org
we've got lots more to come stay with us
after this break
[Music]